Hello everybody and welcome to today's NCBI
webinar.
We will talk about the Genome Data Viewer
today.
This slide has preliminary information you
may need.
Wayne Matten is here with me and he will answer
questions during the webinar when they come
up.
All the questions and answers will be available
after the webinar in a document that will
be linked to our webinars and courses page.
It will also be available in our FTP directory
for this particular webinar, that's the materials
directory there is a compressed URL that will
take you to the directory.
Let's get started.
I will show you up few slides and then we
will do a live demo for the rest of the time.
The Genome Data Viewer is the topic today
and mostly today I will say GDV when I mean
the Genome Data Viewer because it's faster
. My name is Peter Cooper and if you have
questions you can write to me at the address
at the bottom of the slide.
peter.cooper@nih.gov
We will talk about what the Genome Data Viewer
is and we will talk about accessing it.
We will do a brief overview of the interface
and functions and mostly we will demonstrate
it live for you today.
The Genome Data Viewer is now NCBI's main
genome browser and the assembly browser for
eukaryotic organizations and this replaces
the map viewer which was the original genome
browser.
You will recognize the interface which is
similar to other specialized browsers we've
had available like the 1000 genomes browser
and the variation viewer.
Embedded in the center of all of those browsers
and familiar I hope to you is the sequence
viewer panel which is present in other places
like Gene and Nucleotide graphics view.
It has functions for navigating across the
assembly, uploading mapped data and accessing
analysis tools.
Right now in the Genome Data Viewer we have
over 500 eukaryotic RefSeq genomes available.
How do you access it?
There is a homepage that you can easily get
to and the quickest way to find it is search
in Google and it has by default you search
human genome and you can use this tree function
to browse various organisms that you can load
into the Genome Data Viewer.
For example I can expand the node there to
see zebrafish and other bony fishes and it's
a convenient way to navigate and browse by
organism.
Today we will focus on a particular assembly,
actually more than one for a particular organism
and that is the human genome.
You can search with the gene names in the
box, SNP IDs, RefSeq accessions, or chromosome
positions.
You could also pick assembly listed here,
the current reference assembly, GRCh38. or
the previous assembly, GRCh37.
You can also search alternate assemblies,
the HuReF assembly and also the hydatid molar
cell line assembly.
There is a browser function where you can
enter the browser itself with chromosome 1
and you can BLAST a specific database that
contains a particular assembly you are interested
in and this ideogram view allows you to click
and browse a particular chromosome that you
would like.
Another way to get to GDV and these have been
around for a while in various places at NCBI.
So from the Gene I can link to the Genome
Data Viewer and in Assembly I can link to
and browse in the Genome Data Viewer.
And today as a matter of fact we now have
links from BLAST to the Genome Data Viewer
which went live this morning.
Here is the main browser interface and it
should look familiar to you.
Sort of in the middle of it is the graphical
sequence viewer and on the left-hand side
at the top are various search and navigation
features.
If you run a search you can get results in
the ideogram view and it shows you hits on
various chromosomes.
You might find hits on more than one place
as it is a text search.
You can select the one you want from the panel
underneath it.
There are widgets for uploading the data,
adding tracks, loading BLAST results and we
will use those in a few moments when we do
the demonstration.
At the top there are navigation functions
and there is a gene and Exon navigator which
you can take advantage of.
At the very top there is an ideogram with
the chromosome you are on and viewing at this
moment is chromosome 1 and you can use that
as a way to navigate and display various parts
of the chromosome.
Just a little detail on additional functions
and we will use these today and hopefully
we get a chance to use them all but might
not get to all of them.
I can upload my own data and these are the
various kinds of files types listed here on
the slide, BED, GFF, GTF, VCF, HGVS.
I can also use an URL or simply paste the
data in the text box.
I can run BLAST from within the browser and
view the alignments there, and there is a
little tool, the alignment inspector lets
me navigate across my BLAST matches using
either the query coordinate system or the
geneome coordinate system.
I can look at assembly region details.
There are places where we have alternate assemblies
for the human genome because we can't represent
the diversity of the human genome in one particular
assembly so we have ways of browsing those.
Finally there are some NCBI data sets that
are mapped to the assembly and you can load
those to the add tracks function.
You can add all the tracks that are available
in the sequence viewer.
Let's do some live examples.
I will focus on two chromosomes and a couple
of different things on one and an area on
another.
First, we will look at the areas surrounding
the Adenosine Deaminase gene on chromosome
20 a we will add recommended tracksets that
NCBI has and configure the tracks that are
there.
We will upload custom data and show you how
to print and share views from that and from
that particular gene we will run Primer-BLAST
to get primers to amplify an Exon, then we
will BLAST some sequences from different species
and load those into the browser to look at
conservation.
And on chromosome 2 if we get a chance we
will take a look at region 116 which has alternate
assemblies and we will look at the region
surrounding the Lactase gene . In the Lactase
gene we will look at gene expression tracks
as well as ones I made myself from the tracks
available in the sequence viewer that have
to do with Exon coverage.
And then we change assemblies and move from
38 back to 37 and we can upload an SRA data
set.
By the way these are all based loosely on
a set of demos that Wayne did at ASHG a couple
of weeks ago.
If you want to get that particular handout,
which is a nice PDF, there is a link at the
bottom of the slide that will take you there.
https://go.usa.gov/xn2R4
I will escape out of the web browser.
Here is the Genome Data Viewer interface.
You can pick a particular organism and we
selected human for you.
If I want to select a different one I can
do that here.
I can click to expand the nodes as I showed
on the slide a few minutes ago to look for
a particular organism in here.
If I want to search the human genome here
is the way to do it.
I can browse the genome or BLAST against this
assembly and we can pick the assembly here
as I dscused.
I can search for lots of different markers
on the genome.
I will search for Adenosine Deanminase so
let's run that search.
Here we have the region surrounding Adenosine
Deanminase with the default tracks available
here.
Adenosine Deanminase is a gene associated
with severe human phenotypes if there are
mutations, one is severe combined immunodeficiency.
Let's say we are interested in some kind of
clinical features of this particular gene.
I can load the clinical features track by
going up here to the tracks menu and I can
go to the NCBI recommended tracksets here.
I will load the clinical tracks.
We now have the gene map on top for Adenosine
Deanminase and I loaded a number of other
tracks.
This is an interesting one we will focus on
which is the RefSeqGene alignment to the assembly
and it's interesting because these are particular
reagents or records designed specifically
to give you a stable coordinate system with
canonical sequences aligned to them and even
has the Exons spelled out on this transcript.
So we will use that as a way of mapping out
where we are on the Exons of this gene.
Down here are all the variants from dbSNP.
Under that are variations from the ClinVar,
our clinical database that talks about the
relationships between variations and human
phenotypes.
ANd then there are other types of variation
tracks that are large-scale variants, insertions
and duplications and things like that.
There are other tracks that have nothing in
this particular area so I will delete these
tracks.
That's one thing we can do to modify the display
settings.
Now I have a slightly simplified display.
Notice the track for the RefSeqGene record
has an expanded view.
I have a gene bar and the transcript and protein
sequence shown here.
Transcript in blue, the protein is in red.
It might be nice to have this gene view up
here so the Adenosine Deanminase is rendered
in the same way.
You can do that by going to the tracks menu
and configuring the tracks or also configure
the tracks by mousing over the top of the
track and using the gear icon or you can use
a shortcut which is this button that looks
like the tracks and if you click that you
will get various transcripts and protein sequences
shown.
One thing to notice is the transcripts are
shown with a gray background and if you go
to the help document for this track you realize
that's because there are mismatches compared
to the genome.
If I mouse over one of these it will tell
me that.
This transcript has one substitution compared
to this genomic sequence.
That's because the transcript sequences here
are based on mRNA sequences in GenBank, the
genome may have a different variant in it.
Notice there is a red line on the gene record
that shows that it has the mismatch, so it
matches that mRNA sequence.
We can do something interesting and zoom in.
We will zoom in to Exon 2 and I will zoom
to sequence.
So we are zoomed in to the region showing
that particular change between the RefSeqGene
record and the genome.
This mismatch is at the position of a C/T
variant and you see the variant is listed
here.
It is a common variant and you can add a track
to show that.
One thing I noticed about this gene that makes
it a little bit confusing to look at is, notice
this basically is written backwards because
it's on the negative strand of the genome.
I could flip it around if I want to.
Let's go to the tracks menu and add another
track.
We go to configure tracks.
Now I have the opportunity to choose from
a range of tracks.
Let's go to variation tracks.
Some of these are already shown and are checked.
One that is not shown on the clinical track
are the common variants and you see the ones
with global minor allele frequencies of 1%
or more so those would be what we would call
polymorphisms.
You can see indeed this variation that is
present in this person's genome that was used
to assemble this part of the genome has a
variant there.
It is different from and if you look at the
minor allele frequency this actually the minor
allele at this position.
It is a synonymous substitution that doesn't
change the valine code to a different amino
acid.
There are other variants here and these color
codes here and you can look at that by getting
the help document for this particular track.
Purple means they are pathogenic variants
and if you go to ClinVar you realize this
particular one is associated with severe combined
immunodeficiency.
Let's go ahead and now we will do something
a little bit different and let's add some
data ourselves.
We will go to the Your Data widget on the
left-hand side.
I am going to click this button to add files.
This is my file.
This is from the HapMap individual NA12878
and it is a list of HGVS renderings of SNPs
in this particular region for this Gene and
I got this from the genome in a bottle data
available on the NCBI website.
Those variants are showing up for me now in
this track at the bottom and I could have
named the track something more informative
than the name of the file.
You see that person which is from the Utah
population has that SNP as well.
You can navigate along these if you want to
to see where they go, where they are.
Notice some of them are present in dbSNP and
this one in this particular position of the
genome is not present in SNP, so if it's not
an error, then it's a SNP that's not present
in the database.
I can use my Exon navigator to go back to
the Exon 2 we were looking at . Suppose I
like this and interested in saving it and
showing it to someone else, how can I do that?
There are two things you can do.
One is go to the tools menu and click on the
link that says print friendly PDF and you
can create a PDF file right here.
And I can view that.
That is a nice graphic I can use to make a
figure if I want.
The other option you have is to go up here
and click on the link that says share this
page and that gives me a URL I can share with
people and that's good for about 90 days.
Let's go on to use some analysis tools within
the browser and let's move to a different
Exon.
I will close that.
I will go over here to Exon four and I will
center this a little better.
and it is a Exon that has some disease gene
SNPs in it and you can see the pathogenic
SNPs listed here.
If I want to amplify this, to get primers
that will amplify this exon, I can easily
do that.
I go to tools and go to BLAST and primer search
and I will primer BLAST the visible range.
It opens up Primer-BLAST and if I want to
a reasonable thing to do is adjust these ranges
so my primers are binding outside the Exon.
And I can pick the database, in this case
I want to amplify this from genomic DNA and
it is automatically set for me to Homo sapiens.
If I do that, and just to save time I will
show you what the results look like.
so we have a set of primers here.
I can load those.
After I run this they will be available to
me in the graphical sequencer viewer.
If I go to the tracks menu and go to configure
tracks, you notice there is a section called
Primer-BLAST.
I can load those and I have several of them
here because I've run this a bunch of times.
Let me zoom out a little bit so you can see
those.
There they are on the genome so I have them
available and I can see where they would bind
and what sequence they would amplify.
Let me go ahead and get rid of those.
Suppose I want to do some BLAST searching
against this genome.
I can go to a different function or widget
and that is the BLAST widget.
I could go to tools and run a new BLAST search.
I have the ability here to do that and I have
already set this up with parameters that I
want.
I could run the mouse and the cow Adenosine
Deanminase against the genome and I won't
do that but I will go ahead and open this
so you can see what the result looks like.
This file is available on the FTP site if
you want that.
So here are my results and this is what the
mouse alignment looks like to the genome and
this is what the cow alignment looks like
to the genome.
The cow is a little better aligned than the
mouse is.
That blast RID is available over here and
I can go ahead and add it or if it was a new
one, or one I had not run in this way, I could
show it by adding the RID.
This device is a way of navigating across
the different hits.
There is also a separate larger alignment
inspector here.
Notice I have two tracks here.
One is the BLAST results themselves and the
other is something called the cleaned alignment
and those are a little bit more useful because
you see how the hits from the same sequence
are connected to each other.
I can close that one if I don't want to use
it.
You can use this to navigate across matches
based on the messenger RNA sequence or on
the genomic sequence here.
You see the mouse sequence is the one with
a longer accession number and the cow has
a shorter accession number and typically the
cow is a little bit better match but not in
all the exons.
Let's go ahead and do one more quick thing
on chromosome 20.
I don't want to do that yet.
I want to leave chromosome 20 and go to chromosome
2 and we will do a couple of quick things
to show expression and take a look at the
last widget down here on the bottom which
is the assembly region details.
I can jump to chromosome two by going over
here and clicking it from the ideogram view
and now I am on chromosome 2 and I can get
rid of the alignment inspector.
I am zoomed way out and I don't want to search
for adenosine deaminase.
I want to look at a region where there is
a mark undernearth the ideogram which tells
you there is alternate assemblies available
for that particular region.
There also may be some assembly difficulties
in the region and you can look quickly at
this one which is region 116, near the centromere.
It is a region that could be difficult to
assemble.
I am there and I need to add a map that's
going to give me some information about this
particular area so what I want to do is go
to tracks and that track is one of the recommended
tracks which will be Assemblies.
You can see there are number of curation issues
in this region.
There are some clones that don't match the
way we would like.
These are called discordant clones, these
are clone-end sequences.
Here is the map I wanted to focus on and these
are alternate assemblies for this region that
represent alternative versions of this part
of the genome.
If you scroll down a little bit on this genome
you see there is a big gap close by.
I can take one of these and in assembly region
details we see marks which represent places
where this particular sequence, this alternative
locus for example, this alternative assembly
has relative insertion compared to the genome
and I can switch this around and change it
to the one that is master sort of in this
view.
You see when it reloads that the genome has
to be gapped to support that.
Let's do the last thing we came to do today
which is to look at a different place on chromosome
2 which is the region surrounding the lactase
gene.
Here is Lactase and I still have the assembly
support tracks up.
What I will do here is change that and let's
say we are interested in expression so there
is an expression trackset available here.
These are a bunch of Next Generation RNA seq
runs aligned to the genome and are used in
process of annotating things so we can make
splice variants and things like that.
And also give you a way of looking at expression
because these are different tissues or organs.
You can count the number that aligned in various
ways.
Let me return this to the expression track.
Here is sort of the aggregate of this is.
The more interesting thing is to look down
at these which are the individual libraries
and you see this gene is expressed in duodenum,
and that library is labeled small intestine.
We would expect Lactase as a digestive enzyme
predominately to be expressed in infants and
in some cases expressed in adult and we will
come back to that idea in a moment.
Let me zoom out a little bit and this is a
nice example because you see that Lactase
has specific expression in that particular
organ whereas the genes on either side are
more ubiquitously expressed.
These are the intron-spanning reads and there
are other ways of thinking about this.
You can basically look at Exon coverage and
where do these RNA-seq reads align to the
genome and one way to display that is through
the tracks here and I made a set of tracks
by going to the configure menu and loading
them into the browser and basically saving
them into my NCBI account.
You can definitely save them if you want to.
We have already done that for you.
Here is one that I saved.
Certainly you get similar results and these
are no longer spanning the introns but highlighting
for you the Exons.
And we also get expression again in the duodenum
library.
The last trick I want to do for you today
is let's change the assembly and load a track
that we have already that is aligned to this.
I will cheat.
There are lots of ways to change the assembly
like go back to the genome data viewer home
page and switch it there but I think we will
add the ability to do that to the Genome Data
Viewer page directly in a little bit but not
there yet.
I will change the assembly version just by
cheating and typing the .25 in there.
You see now on that I'm on GRCh37 patch 13
zoomed out on chromosome 1.
I can put us in a place we are familiar with
let's find the Lactase gene.
Now I want to upload a track and this is a
track available here as one of the supported
accession types.
This is a SRA run for the library RP 11 which
comprises 70% of the genome sequence.
Remember only one allele is included in the
reference assembly so it will be interesting
to see what the other allele is this person
has.
I will load that.
The same kind of thing we saw before where
there are red places are the mismatches so
there are places where this person is heterozygous
for positions in the lactase gene.
We will do one last search and look for the
SNP that's responsible for, in some populations,
the persistence of lactase activity in adulthood,
what provides people the ability to drink
milk without gastrointestinal distress.
I will go ahead and load that SNP to look
at the genotype at that position.
Here is the SNP I am talking about.
I will search instead of the gene which we
have been doing all day, I will search with
this particular SNP.
It lands me right here and I am in a different
gene, MCM6.
All these SNPs landing in the promoter of
the lactase gene so it's upstream relatively
speaking.
You see this person is a heterozygote for
this change and has the A allele at this position
that allows lactase to be expressed in adulthood.
The G is the one in the genome assembly is
the most common allele worldwide is the one
that is incorporated into this part of chromosome
2.
And of course you can zoom out and see that
this is near the, if I change the region and
go to Gene with pad to zoom out a little bit
faster and I will slide it over a little bit
and there is lactase over here and upstream
of it is MCM6.
That's a lot I did today and maybe a little
bit too much and we ran a little over the
time but let's go ahead and pause and answer
any questions that we can and if we don't
have any questions we will take a couple of
minutes to let people think if they have any.
I will share the slide with you at the end
and there are a number of useful links on
the slide for the Genome Data Viewer and also
a help document as well as a YouTube video
that Wayne made that is an overview of the
Genome Data Viewer.
There is a fact sheet available on the FTP
site.
In general please check out our YouTube channel
and we make videos of all of our webinars
and put instructional videos up there.
There is a Learn page at NCBI which you can
get to from the homepage . That URL will take
you to the fact sheets on just about any NCBI
resource you can think of.
And if you have questions check out our support
center . There are a lot of answers to questions
there, and you can also write to the help
desk from that page.
Wayne doesn't see any questions so if you
have questions about the webinars in general
you can write to us at the address given,
webinars@ncbi.nlm.nih.gov.
If you have general NCBI questions you can
use the support center link on the previous
slide or write to info@ncbi.nlm.nih.gov and
of course you can always write to me, peter
dot cooper at NIH.gov.
Thank you for coming and I will go ahead and
end the webinar.